oh sorry support us why am I wearing
these because I love it
never take those off what's browser
history happy holidays everybody this is
gonna be my Christmas special video we
finally got to see Capaldi regenerate
into Jodie Whittaker even though it's
sort of our second first look at her so
just careful for spoilers from the
episode there's a whole bunch of Easter
eggs to cover if you are just finding me
for the first time be sure to subscribe
to get everything
the story twice upon a time is basically
them using the first doctors
regenerations story from tenth planet to
tell the story of Capaldi's regeneration
into jodie Whitaker's 13th doctor so the
whole idea is that he's been putting off
her generation he's afraid and they even
sort of retcon the first doctor's
regeneration when he says that he's
afraid don't worry you haven't told
anyone else technically because he was
telling himself the villain or the
antagonist of the episode even though
they didn't turn out to be an antagonist
was the testimony which is actually a
metaphor for the testimony of the dead
people of the past the glass people that
they used a copy memories it was cool
them to bring Jenna Coleman back in the
way that they brought Matt Smith's first
companion Amy Pond back for his
regeneration for like that final goodbye
but I love the way that they
incorporated the footage from 10th
planet in the intro the most epic
previously on that we've ever had on
Doctor Who
previously on 709 episodes and even
though technically there's more than 800
episodes of Doctor Who I think that
number is sort of a joke on the idea of
the Lost episodes so technically I think
it's over 830 episodes maybe a little
bit more than that at this point David
Bradley is always great as the first
doctor because this was the Christmas
special they played up the humor a
little bit more just to make it a little
bit happier for families to watch
together
if I hear anymore language like that
from you young lady you're in for a
jolly go to smack awesome it's speaking
of bringing people back if they keep
bringing him back year after year he
will eventually have played the first
doctor as much as William Hartnell
played the first doctor I don't quite
think he'll get there but Mark Gatiss
comes back is the ancestor of
lethbridge-stewart Kate Stewart's father
so they had a big joke at the end please
look in on my family from time to time
oh I promise you he will do just that
because I think pretty much every
version of the doctor starting with the
second doctor has had some sort of
interaction with unit at some point over
the years mostly third doctor fourth
doctor but they always keep coming back
to it at least once or twice per season
so because this was Capaldi's final
episode in Moffitt's final episode there
were a lot of Easter eggs for things
from early in Capaldi's run like rusty
was a big twist of the episode it was
good to see him again but there were
also a lot of jokes about Moffat era
Doctor Who as well as classic who always
a lot of classic who Easter eggs but
because this is Moffitt's final episode
mostly Moffat era Doctor Who jokes the
doctors met versions of himself many
many times before I think there's been
about four times that the doctor has met
the first version of himself but usually
for moments like this where they really
play up the comedy people point to the
50th anniversary where Matt Smith and
David Tennant were comparing each other
Sonic's like oh you're not quite as good
as me
[Music]
regeneration most of the first half of
the episode with the first doctor is you
just remembering all the stuff that's
changed since the first doctors run well
I guess Paulie isn't around anymore what
happened to your TARDIS it seems like
it's bigger than it's supposed to be
doctor who is one of those few shows
that can make fun of itself while also
paying homage to itself and just having
a really nice moment like Jodie
Whittaker when she regenerates her first
word is brilliant so it's sort of like
her saying oh wow this is amazing but
it's also sort of a joke about them
saying that the episode was amazing
pretty much every big speech that the
characters got in the episode was a
metaphor for Doctor Who itself the
character as well as the series but also
why it's important so the doctor himself
was realizing why it's important that he
needs to regenerate and he should not
die like this shouldn't be his final
self but also that the show itself in
real life should continue on and why
it's important to everyone probably the
most important part of the episode was
that last big speech that he was
speaking to his future self as he was
going out it included Easter eggs from a
whole bunch of different things
including Capaldi stuff in real life
never be cruel never be cowardly was the
speech from the 50th anniversary he told
me the name you chose was a promise what
was the promise run like hell because
you'll always need to was taken from a
Red Nose Day special during 1999 when he
stopped for a second and said never eat
pears that's actually from a David
Tennant deleted scene on five very
important five don't let me eat pears
I hate pears probably one of the best
Easter eggs is the one for Capaldi in
real life so when he initially became
the doctor people were asking him
questions about the doctors name and he
says I'm not the writer I don't get to
pick what his name is but the part about
children understanding the doctor's name
was taken directly from that speech so
that's actually something that Capaldi
said in real life it's not something
that they made up from the episode but
most of the rest of it is all River Song
stuff he told River Song his name so
just more Moffat era Doctor
references because River Song is a
Moffat character even though she debuted
during david tennant era but let me know
in the comments what was your favorite
moment from the episode what did you
think about it as far as Christmas
specials go and what do you think about
Jodie Whitaker's version of the doctor
so far her falling from the TARDIS is
also a nice callback to Matt Smith
crashing the TARDIS in his first episode
- like you regenerate you destroy the
TARDIS but they use that as a way to
explain how they redesigned the interior
so it'll be interesting to see if they
do that for Jodie Whittaker because it's
actually pretty expensive to do usually
when they design new TARDIS interiors it
winds up costing them at least a couple
million dollars but we'll probably hear
about that in the next couple of months
I know I haven't talked a whole lot
about Bill in the episode but that's
because I feel like the way they
included her sort of trampled on her
goodbye that she got in the actual
finale like it was this really nice way
of sending her off she was going off on
this grand adventure but now explaining
the glass version of bill it's like nope
she's got this version of her here it's
the same person they were trying to
spend the entire episode telling you
that it was the exact same version even
though it was really just her memories
uploaded into a body I don't know if
there's a way that you could actually do
the episode without including the most
recent companion so really cool that
bill was in the episode but not so much
with the way that they included her that
was really my only thumbs down just the
way they retconned her goodbye from the
finale and I was never really a big fan
of nardole but I shouldn't have been
surprised that they brought him back to
because apparently now everybody in the
history of human existence gets uploaded
to this database so theoretically the
show now has a way to explain how they
can bring back any dead character as one
of these glass people which feels like
it tramples on a lot of the meaningful
deaths the characters have had during
this new who run or even classic who -
because remember this is the entirety of
human history that they upload to these
glass people but let me know how you
feel about that just as long as they
don't start carding out dead characters
every single week they think it'd be
okay so what's gonna happen is is
throughout the holidays I'll be posting
videos like I normally would if you have
any special requests just leave them in
the comment
below but click here for that new black
panther trailer that I just posted and
click here for all my Star Wars the last
Jedi Easter eggs thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
happy holidays